pop
[Musique]
thibault
non
[Musique]
mentir
le vrai problème
déjà comme les hommes politiques vous ne
répondez pas aux questions bien on a
terminé cette émission avec albert
simonin est-ce que ce langage des
économistes bercy minable intéresse nous
touche peut-être dream passionne compris
l'économie pour l'homme de plume elle
est mensuel
c'est la rolls du bistrot le tailleur le
loyer un petit peu pour la rue de rivoli
enfin vous voyez ce que je veux dire
alors s'il reste un petit chouya pour le
tiercé le perniflars ben alors tout va
bien merci albert simonin merci gérard
plantié je rappelle le titre de votre
ouvrage
au delà du socialisme bonsoir à tous
liberty
[Musique]
on va souper dans un troquet ce voulez
vous joindre à nous ah non je suis
désolé mais il faut que j'entre ex tant
pis pour nous
bonne soirée et à bientôt à bientôt
merci mademoiselle monsieur
avec un chat c'est pareil les écoles
amies c'est râpé bon maintenant explique
moi sérieusement qu'est ce que c'est que
ça l'a plus fait voilà prévenus eh bien
on veut ça veut dire que le travail des
ouvriers vaut beaucoup plus que les
salaires que le patron leur donne donc
c'est
ben voila tu as tout compris
si tu laisses pas les gens gagner un peu
de fric je me vois pourquoi il casserait
la tête serait pas un peu de droite toit
des fois extrême droite
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
on était jeunes 18 monsieur plantier 17
inventeur et moi je vous ai dis merde
souvenez vous
[Musique]
laissez moi passer votre numéro de trion
ça suffit' fun salle ça mon petit bijou
c'est des colts si tu ne bouges te
permets de pisser sur la moquette promis
c'était peut-être un autre
[Applaudissements]
oui qu'on paye
[Musique]
ans
là
[Musique]
on va jusqu'à 10 heures à l'air au alors
n'a fait que rappeler le bon vin blanc
la presse ne s'y intéresseraient patron
s'il s'agissait pas mais qu'il inconnu
on l'a pris son argent
carnet de chèques on a pu aussi l'argent
dans le sac de sa petite amie 300 francs
qui est la petite amie une certaine
françoise muller elle habite ici au
sixième elle est entendue
voilà passé la nouvelle brigade des
agressions et puis ensuite pas rentrer
chez elle ment face à se comprendre
j'ai perdu mon petit carnet elle vivait
avec gérard tout y est oui depuis
quelques mois mais domicile de plantier
ccsa maire d'urrugne rue du colombier
françoise muller est à nice avec lui
contre l'émission de télévision sont
entrés directement sur aix ils ont pris
la route vers eux
bon je crois que c'est 11h30
ils sont arrivés ici vers 1h45 un beau
de la mercedes là deux hommes étaient
cachés et sont sortis de l'ombre
ils les ont menacés courte bagarre à
l'équipe a tiré et plantier s'est
effondré les filles et bats la fille et
la cour jusqu'à l'ascenseur qui
heureusement était là elle s'est sauvée
créé monte chez elle et à l'appeler mais
des bruits secours et wiki nécessaire
pour moi ça me vient tirer un sas et
possédant noir d'après la fille sait
combien cette quinzaine de mètres s'est
passé dans le voir la minute ou deux
têtes et atmel savez vous étés
l'ascenseur hommes plutôt jeunes étaient
armés de pistolets trois balles dans le
corps de la victime
le gardien de l'immeuble lui prétend
avoir entendu quatre coups de feu
regardez oui hélas dagorn lucien
bouchard monsieur ancien sergent-chef du
quatrième étranger invalides à 75% très
bien très bien dit monsieur vous êtes
absolument sûr que vous avez entendu
quatre coups de revolver jose dur mais
il n'y a pas du tout de traces de balles
non les hommes de l'identité en vérifier
moi je suis sûre ou avec les viets
fallait pas avoir les orients sable et
moi je vous le dis parce que eh bien
monsieur dagorn je vous remercie et je
vous qu'on veut créer ultérieurement à
monsieur à aux ordres la dame de la vue
alors je veux en tant que cette photo
est binaire préférerions qu'il n'y en
notre petite enquête à son sujet et qui
choisit ses amis savaient donc ça veut
rien dire j'ai demandé sur elle tous les
renseignements avec le modèle de marcel
où je ne pense pas que je la voyais plus
tôt possible
demain par exemple tu vous n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient
mais je n'y vois aucun inconvénient
marchés envers commissaire
c'est le juge d'instruction cette bonne
femme oui à la menace au mas au lasso
c'est pas le tout mixé d'étuis en
bagnole qui elle était avocate autrefois
mais l'emploi du service comme juge
après la mort de son mari
blavier lui ou son bouquin un plantier
non non moi non plus il paraît que
oui
[Musique]
repas c'est un peu bizarre vous qu'on
assassine juste après son passage à la
télé mais je sais pas encore nicolas bon
je vous ramène chez vous pourquoi ben on
est vendredi ni un jour du pp week end
et du pp il n'a pas perdu la main or pas
du tout et manger avec nous verrez c'est
très très bon non non merci
sa cuisine j'aime bien mais les
histoires du mouton à cinq pattes je
commence à les connaître
et oui moi aussi ses pensées ses pairs
de mon mari
tête à millau
lui dirais que c'est vraiment bien ses
toiles jamais wii pc mois
vous y prend un petit plan secte avant
demande je n'ai jamais fait de mal à
personne mais c'est un signe des temps
le mignon s'est contenté en cinq mois le
docteur lemaignen cependant le pas pour
longtemps
si tu vois des amines tessin - je te
prépares est de ces pop y est tu m'en
diras des nouvelles meilleures bp
peut-être mais donc vis regarde ce qui
se dit en tête devant lui
je passais une mare a compté un régime
dont 800 libre à ses toiles qui s'occupe
de l'histoire du professeur oui c'était
un professeur de quoi tu as un
professeur de sciences économiques
c'était drôle de métier toute l'île et
des histoires comme ça pour que pourquoi
maintenant paris
ça c'est la nouvelle musique je me
demande avec quoi on les a vacciné tous
ces jeunes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
key
[Musique]
en tant que telle a pas j'arrive
tu as écouté ça te plaît si julie sait
très bien que moi j'en suis resté ici
raven ça sens non à 506 nos joueurs non
mais il est aux truffes de france
j'ai entraîné du kindle c'est bien ça tu
m'avais pas dit alors je suis venue te
rapporter ça de la part de nicolay baril
c'est très très bien a ajouté sept coups
de marseille là pour le l'audition du
groupe là on est tous engagés ça
marchait assez bien pour tout l'été
ouais c bat du pin passaient à la fac
pour toute inscription non on va pas
remettre ça sur le tapis et vient dîner
c'est prêt oui il t'a pas dit quand père
moi j'en mange pas de vos paupières j'ai
tout à fait au courant mais peut-être
que tu pourrais manger tout riz brun
avec nous vous ferez plaisir
on n'est pas égal est aussi un temps
fort
oui
je jour
j'étais appelé hier soir c'était pas
chez toi non ce n'était pas ce que tu
veux dire que ton protéger les toujours
pas passé s'inscrire en fac
alors soyons petit dimanche tu dean
dimanche
beaucoup se fait 25 ans que pose la même
question tous les vendredis oui je dîne
dimanche et ont beau père va nous
exécuter samat haulotte avant de
repartir pour marty oui je crois que ce
sera une charlotte très bon parce que
moi je suis fatigué ça fait dix ans son
père mais manquent ni n'a vraiment
jamais autant manquer construit mais un
mot aussi me manque mais si tu le foot
un peu la paix à guillaume que c'est
beau la guitare c'est difficile à
guitare puis c'est pas honteux la
guitare et moi je t'emmerde
je revois la france populaire à eelv a
fait la rentrée
[Musique]
mazel maire s'il vous plaît
mazel muller
très bonne nouvelle
bonjour mademoiselle s'essayer oui vous
vous appelez françoise muller et vous
êtes né le 13 novembre 1945 à marc ooms
cette directive vous avez encore vos
parents mes parents j'avais une
profession afin de rencontrer gérard
j'étais par mail ou ça dans plusieurs
établissements
le dernier set carreno à marseille et
maintenant vous êtes vous êtes domicilié
à aix en provence au 26 rue déserte où
il entend vous habitez là depuis trois
mois et vous connaissez la victime a
raconté depuis peu plus tôt ou tard
depuis le début de l'année elle était sa
maîtresse
gérard vrai qu'on se marie et vous parce
que vous dites de gérard voulait qu'on
se marie c'est un peu restrictif
je pensais pas que mariage c'était
indispensable mais je suis ravie voulait
sûrement me prouver qu'il n'avait pas de
préjugés pourquoi par rapport au fait
que vous aviez été barmaid ou qu'est ce
que font vos parents
on peut arrêter les retraites mais avant
et travailler au top à marseille ait
lieu
est-ce que vous avez craint que cette
différence de situation sociale vos
cause pour plus tard l'embarras ou pas
du tout pourquoi voudriez-vous que sa
part a voulu que d'essayer des ennemis
n'ont pas hésité il avait peut-être des
amis politiques mais je les connaissais
pas moi et vous intéresser à ce qu'il
écrivait ses articles à ses livres
j'aimais bien le temps de parler même de
choisir quand je prenais pas toujours
bon et bien vous allez vous raconter ce
qui s'est passé ce soit côté j'ai déjà
tout raconter un détail aux policiers ah
oui je sais bien mais ça va être très
pénible mais je suis absolument oublier
de vous reposer les questions très bien
on est arrivé de nice on veut juste se
carrer deux hommes sont sortis de
l'ombre ou lycées fermés ou les deux
[Musique]
enfin je sais pas ça s'est passé très
vite vous pouvez les décrire le garage
est très mal éclairée
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'ils nous
ont demandé notre argent
et à ce moment là la minuterie cette
étape
gérard est sorti de la voiture et un
début de bagarre et le premier coup de
feu alors j'ai eu peur j'ai couru vers
l'ascenseur et ils n'ont pas eu les
doigts attrapé il s'occupait de gérard
et vous êtes notre appartement vous avez
appelé police secours
oui et vous n'avez pas eu envie de
demander de l'aide ou de d'alerté
monsieur monsieur dagorn le gardienne de
l'immeuble cas il faudrait une caisse
qui aurait pu faire oui il est vrai que
il a bien entendu quatre coups de feu
mais qu'il n'a pas jugé utile d'aller
voir ce qui se passait vous vous avez
déclaré que vous aviez entendu trois
coups de feu
peut-être c'est très bien pu me tromper
il était 1h 45 ans vous avez appelé
police comment j'ai pas vraiment pensé
un quart des manoeuvres ce que je sais
c'est que j'ai eu du mal à les avoir
vous avez aussi déclaré avoir quitté
l'iss à 11h30
mais l'interview télévisée de gérard
plantié s'est terminée à 10h45
c'est possible combien de temps vous
avez 1000 pour faire le trajet de nice
est un peu plus de deux heures oui vous
êtes rentré directement de nice à aix en
provence
non gérard s'est arrêtée au drugstore
pour acheter le monde et il ya eu un
embouteillage la sortie de nice
créer des décalages de temps bon bah
écoutez muller je vous remercie tous
seraient tout pour aujourd'hui je vous
reverrai d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas
l'intention de l'ex en ce moment
j'aimerais vous poser encore une
question
gérard plantié lui
oui madame jamie jarre ne voudriez pas
que pur devront payer des dépositions
sombre merci mademoiselle
[Musique]
les ballons oui nicolas elle est belle
le carillon à marseille c'est pas un bar
du truand ce shérif ironique la halle
aux madmoizelles gevrey le commissaire
marne et s'il vous plaît pour le sujet
massot à l'aube au jour que viscères
alors je viens d'entendre françoise
muller oui bayard il ya pas mal de
choses à vérifier surtout sur le plan
des horaires et puis est ce que vous
vous rappelez si vous avez retrouvé dans
la voiture de plantier le numéro du
monde du du 18 mai non
bon mes coudes et tout ce que vous
pourrez m'apporter à propos de françoise
muller m'intéresserait éternellement
merci voir albert des gags villa d'aller
me chercher
votre avocat n'est pas là
il devait venir mais celui-là il n'est
jamais pressé et que quand c'est pour me
demander des sous dans des cars vous
mais motyl j'ai entendu votre femme et
elle affirme qu'elle est toujours avec
vous des rapports sexuels a pas moi je
suis une nature mais on sait aussi ça
n'explique quand même pas pourquoi vous
forcer votre fils est couché avec vous
si vous croyez que tout le monde il est
si riche ce pour aller se payer des
[ __ ] marseille avec gérard madame
aussi premier assure la création
professeur de faculté à 30 ans c'est
brillant
mon mari est mort en déportation
monfils qu'on assassine erard vivait
avec moi l'appartement est très grand il
n'était pas toujours là et voyager et
collaboré au 6e tour il travaille
énormément
dites-moi mail m vous étiez au courant
de sa vie sentimentale
il est beau garçon des choses sans
lendemain jusqu'à ce qu'il rencontre 7
françoise voulait un colis si je n'ai vu
qu'une fois il ya un mois environ pour
ce conte sans présence
il m'a annoncé qu'ils allaient se marier
comme s'ils avaient craint de le dire
cela seul
pourquoi cette crainte
gérard morin s'est soumis de brossette
fabre en trois mois il avait changé
considérablement les origines sociales
de françoise muller vous génie vous
croyez pas ça on regarde mon mari était
député socialiste et notre fils vous le
savez a hérité de nos idées qui se marie
avec la fille d'un ouvrier et quelque
chose en elle qui m'a gêné dès que j'ai
vu mademoiselle müller sur l'attitude
son regard une intuition
je me trompe rarement et puis cette
histoire d'un appartement rue dès lors
tous qu'elle a pas retenu est celui
gérard havyarimana muller à son noël et
se connaissaient depuis deux mois pleins
mais votre fils avait de l'argent
l'année dernière il avait hérité
d'environ 70 millions de mon oncle et
l'appartement coûté à peu près dans les
combien dont les 50 millions je crois
même si sir que j'ai barré par marie
l'avais pas rencontrée cette fille
tunisair a pris il ya du neuf ans comme
müller n'est pas inconnu au bataillon
laissez nous un instant compris alves je
vous la mène oui à 5 heures sais-tu
croire qu'on va le relâcher ça lui fera
un choc salutaire
ça nous vient de la brigade des moeurs
de marseille à l'été la maîtrise de
reprise justice et elle s'est prostituée
mais c'est surtout sa libido ah oui en
effet d'ailleurs le commissaire
bastionnée nous a donné des
renseignements plus complet alors je
voulais review 163 françoise muller
rencontre un certain maurice redon à nos
clients se dire assez sérieux
à l'époque elle a 18 ans et les
vendeuses et elle plaque tout famille et
boulot pour vivre truands et c'est
redoux qui l'a mis sur le trottoir
et ben non figurez vous redon lespwa
proprement parler un souteneur et vit
plutôt nul le charme de son revolver en
66 il est tombé pour vol à main armée il
en a pris pour sept ans et c'est pendant
sa détention que müller émises au turf
enfin qu'urgent de luxe dans
l'appartement redon bénéficie d'une
remise de peine et il sort en 71 pendant
cinq ans françoise muller pu mettre de
l'argent de côté elle s'est associée
avec un certain
jean paul césari peroni pour prendre un
bar à marseille
le cari no way elle a dit qu'elle allait
et et barmaids au casino c'est à dire
que fa 71
elle cède ses parts à maurice redon
reste derrière le comptoir
le casino a été fermé dès 15 jours dans
le cadre des mesures contre le
proxénétisme mais elle a quitté la boîte
en mars m'a séduite par le professeur de
sciences économiques qui justement venez
d'hérité 70 millions oui c'est menem
plantier maire qui met 10 est a priori
bon vous êtes gentils vous fait taper
tout ça oui
et puis moi je voudrais bien entendre
monsieur renaud rapidement possible
il est arrivé le 15
à les regarder mais qu'est ce que voulez
vous les cas on est plutôt des amis
alors on et moi de lui dire un petit
bonjour en passant que allez-y ça lui
fera sûrement plaisir et à la piscine
non tu viens de seconde de bois revient
la paix crapuleuses
on essaie d'oublier les mauvais jours je
vois ça après un verre
qu'est ce qui me vaut l'honneur à bonloc
est qu'est ce que tu veux et quand on
encaisse on tombe toujours sur les mêmes
ce qui se dresse avec lui et oui c'est
des flics ma jolie et moi je trouve que
de noël soient exemptes à sion le
rapport que je vais vous lire nous a été
fournie par les services de police
d'accord avec ce qui est dans les termes
sont pas très agréables
vous auriez dû me dire que vous aviez
été propriétaire du casino parce que je
pensais que c'était pas très important
de toute façon j'étais permettre en même
temps à des chiots dans ce rapport
beaucoup de choses c'est pas un peu à
ces choses là vous pensiez quand vous
m'avez dit la dernière fois que plante
qui voulait absolument vous prouver
qu'il n'avait pas de préjugés pourquoi
vous avez quitté brice ruraux parce que
j'ai rencontré gérard chose vous
l'aimiez ou non j'avais 18 ans quand
j'ai rencontré maurice m'a sorti d'un
travail et djokovic hlm de mes parents
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le milieu
j'étais la femme de maurice un point
c'est tout et je me suis conduite comme
je le devais quand il est tombé
enfin quand il est allé en prison
le clou de prostituées pour lui il ya
pire que de se prostituer madame chute
assez lucratif quand même parce que à sa
sortie de prison 71 monstre dont a pu
s'acheter un bar garino day
vous avez repris la vie commune
oui mais maurice et les beaucoup changé
on disputait sans arrêt parce qu'il
avait rencontré une autre fille est
aussi étrange que cela puisse vous
paraître je suis d'un tempérament pas
être du tout enfin c'est à ce moment-là
que j'ai quitté varices
entre temps vous avez rencontré plantier
en mars
non c'est ça commence quand ils soient
dedans après cette rupture comme il y
avait une autre fille dans la tête ça
s'est passé très bien depuis la rupture
vous l'avez or vu deux ou trois fois
c'est quand la dernière c'était en avril
dans un bar à marseille et tout ça n'a
rien à voir avec la mort de gérard
pourquoi vous posez toutes les questions
vous allez me dire aussi que c'était
gérard plantié qui avait acheté
l'appartement de la rue du retour j'ai
envie de vous le dire
et alors non rien moi je sais qui vous
êtes
à une phase plus qu'autre chose c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre monsieur faso une vraie
charlotte se fait 48 heures à la rage a
expliqué vino ta mère n'a pas fait un
peu dans l'instauration à un moment
donné puisqu'elle devient maintenant
bateau-mère son commerce d'antiquités à
draguignan et sastre alors elle se plaît
elle gémit mais s'il a eu 6 l/100 mes
oreilles ou ça plutôt rigolo mais ça a
changé tous ces [ __ ] qui raconte à
tout le monde comment ils ont réussi
dans la vie ça existe des gens qui ont
réussi une en plein de même qu'ils sont
pas nécessairement des [ __ ] pour ça
nous non dans la magistrature tu veux
dire
l'ubs je t'en prie je suis habitué de
métier qu'on peut pas faire quoi c'est
tout oui oui bien sûr bien sûr ce moment
il faut que tu saches dit l'homme que ta
mère c'est l'exception qui confirme la
règle
tu as par exemple quand nous étions à la
fac tous les deux parce que nous avons
été à la fac
eh bien elle était aussi absolu aussi
péremptoire que toi dans ses jugements
et on perd aussi d'elle
et le plus drôle c'est que c'est la
mienne de mer qui leur faisaient des
discours pour une beauté nous me direz
mais elle portait encore plus fort que
nous cependant des directions
complètement farfelu et et marc anthony
et n'empire
encore un peu du chef-d'oeuvre
faites moi plaisir non c'est moi je dis
moi et les temps à faire d'économistes
on peut les journaux délire complètement
jeu l'histoire de truands la maîtresse
de gérard planté appartenu au milieu en
milieu tu crois au milieu c'est pas une
histoire de ford corse a en fait tu te
fous de ma vie dieu existe il est
peut-être des choses qui ont changé mais
il existe c'est ya peut-être moins de
coups de couteau il se tire peut-être
plus de chèque
mais il existe enfin nous sommes passés
de françois 1er à louis philippe il ya
plus d'hommes n'empêche pas encore
quelques-uns pour bien dire merde à
petit doigt tu crois chars
car je tenais le mouton à cinq pattes
j'en avais dans ma clientèle des caïds
comme on disait et des nervis des nerfs
mais ils sont devenus des caïds et bien
dans le fond le rêve que de
respectabilité les jambois leur petit
chez les jésuites et oui mais c'est pas
de cela je parle alors de qui parlait du
yom
je veux parler de ceux qui finissent pas
dans les affaires guillaume tu confond
trop facilement dexter est un anarchiste
mais pas du tout ce n'est pas du tout
mais je voulais savoir le fond de la
pensée moyen des concerts je préfère
savoir en liberté que des procureurs de
la république en exercice
merci mon chéri parce que tu m'as fait
peur hein tu me tailler nous parler d'un
juge d'instruction avait longtemps le
manque de foncier muller alors je
pourrai chargés de la surveiller fait ce
qu'elle veut la nuit du 17 au 18 mai
devrait passer au à sainte croix en
compagnie de mes ailes evelyne ne
fleuret oui c'est pas bien qu'est ce que
tu fais dans la vie mais mais elle
ferait deux études de droit elle a
peut-être devenir juge d'instruction
maintenu toutes les situations brillante
mais sur une eau à huy
ah oui nous y voilà proxénétisme
les petits rats moody's indique
attention madame le juge est peut-être
été un voyons méchoui par mc réalisé
m'expliquer pourquoi françoise muller
est connu des services de la mondaine ça
c'est françois s'il a fait sa propre
initiative pour me venir en aide pendant
que j'étais en taule mais dès que je
suis sortie je lui fais tout de suite a
redit son petit commerce et ça je peux
le prouver
c'est très bien et vous félicite
monsieur renaud mois gérard plantié les
canuts et on le connaître quand j'ai vu
où on s'était croisé ya quelques mois
j'avais un intellectuel pour choses à se
dire n'avait jamais eu d'animosité
contre lui
il ya pas de raison d'en vouloir un
homme qui vous prend votre femme
si c'est pas un ami et pourtant je
croyais que dans notre milieu et le
milieu j'ai rien à voir avec le milieu
mois des inventions de flics ça vous met
n'importe quoi sur le dos dès qu'on a un
casier à un core i5 à mexico alors je
comprends pas bon eh ben je remercie nos
sur u2 com il est possible que j'aie
avons ré entendre jusqu'à sainte croix
je me repose je sens qu'un joueur
pourrait rejoindre très bien et bonnes
vacances
[Musique]
tu vois que vous n'avez pas perdu les
habitudes de la maison
hélas au revoir madame le juge vous dis
bon plaisir sais pas si vous avez
remarqué ses yeux moi j'aimerais pouvoir
après sa femme mais pour tout vous dire
moi non plus nicolas tu finis à quelle
heure auparavant cette heure je te
ramène wii se retrouver la sortie
d'accord salut toi salut t'arrêter
contenterait cet après-midi parce que
j'ai avec un canard monroe qui m'a
expliqué que les milieux ça n'existait
pas qui sort l'excellent manga figure
celle des cadets distinguer ce qu'il
fait il est du milieu
non mais attends caïd nervis nervis
futur cahier dossier hokkaido ne les
méritent pas
oh
c'est pas gagné
[Musique]
gardiens regarde
là
oui ce regard-là guillaume blais tapas
avec comme bouge surtout par ion mais
non mais passe à papa passa passa il
mendie pas fait la moche mais moi je
peux pas me permet d'avoir un fils qui
fait la manche érable seulement ton
[ __ ] il faut laisser guillaume
tranquille il a besoin de se libérer de
toi tu comprends pas l'argent qu'il
gagne en ce moment n'a rien à voir avec
l'argent que tu lui donnes mais doit
aussi bien dans la tête
oui
[Musique]
allô oui madame n'est pas encore rentré
on a va sûrement pas tarder attendez je
crois que la voilà c'est de la part de
qui
madame vous planquer gentil
alors oui bonjour madame comment allez
vous oui et bien sûr non non non non non
non je ne peux absolument pas vous
entendre par téléphone non non c'est
tout à fait illégal
alors ne me dit rien maintenant madame
peut que gêner je ne peux pas vous
entendre maintenant mais si vous voulez
je passerai de mâcher vous vers vers 15
heures si ça vous convient
et là je vous entendre et je serai très
fier
ça me fait rire c'est comme ça a marché
quoi donc on sert à manger tu m'as vu
oui je t'ai vu
voyez pas mal
c'est un jour tu avais l'idée de
plaquettes en bouleau pourrait faire
marcher la maison enfin monsieur si vous
avez des révélations à faire vous auriez
pu faire brigade criminelle
si vous me connaissiez vous m'imaginez
auriez mal donnant des renseignements la
police c'est à dire madame plantier qui
voulait absolument que je vous rencontre
monsieur gaudin est un ami d'enfance de
gérard ils ont fait leurs études
ensemble vous êtes économie souci non je
suis professeur de philosophie au lycée
d'hommes et qu'est ce que vous avez à
dire à propos du meurtre
gérard se confier un georges je
connaissais françoise muller depuis deux
ans à peu près vous l'avez connu avant
gérard pont qui n'ont suivi il était
très amoureux de cette fille elle ne me
plaisait pas beaucoup
j'ai fait part de mes impressions mais
et voulait la sortir de son milieu
pensez vous que
françoise muller aimait vraiment j'ai
raconté peut-être face à face on vous
avez tout reprendre depuis le liban
orient
quand gérard plantié rencontré françoise
muller maurice redon était toujours
incarcéré
oui mais je ne savait pas à ce moment là
j'ignorais son existence il est sorti de
prison fin 71 me disais oui et tout de
suite il a menacé gérard il l'a mis à la
demande il réclamait 5 millions pour lui
laisser françoise si j'ai ralenti qui
voulait raconter ça oui j'ai
l'impression qu'au début il a cédé sa il
me l'a pas dit et puis redon a dû
recommencer à le rançonner alors c'est
là qu'ils lâchent de revolver pour se
défendre
tu m'avais lierre 7,65 je crois sans me
dire où il se l'était procuré
et toi vous avez attendu huit jours pour
me raconter tout ça je ne crois pas
beaucoup à la justice que pour présenter
des galas du fonctionnaire comme vous
d'ailleurs je suis mon travail et mon
travail consistait à découvrir la vérité
voilà alors attendez-vous quand même
être convoqué par le commissaire marne
et qui dirige les enquêtes parce que
votre témoignage est très très important
alors là évidemment c'est autre chose
lamanda un type qui veut sortir une
fille de la prostitution c'est classique
bon très bas on va arrêter redon et on
va le garder à vue pendant 48 heures
pour renault magie comique on est un
petit peu
qu'est ce qu'il sait rien enfin rien
elle cherche du travail où elle fait
semblant a il ya un élément qui veut de
vous intéresser
l'associé de redon au parc arino jean
paul perreault ni pour la retrouver dans
une clinique
oui il a été blessé au cours d'une rixe
avec des arabes à marseille je veux le
mont royal officier de police demain je
pense pour l'obtenir grand chose c'est
un coriace deux hommes des arabes nous
insulter
j'ai voulu corriger un son copain a
sorti un revolver et me tirer une balle
dans le ventre
je me suis effondrée nous piquer ce que
j'avais sur moi
environ 400 francs et ma montre bracelet
en or c'est vraiment plus possible de se
promener tout seul dans les rues de
marseille
ça s'est passé le 18 mai vers 1h30 du
matin
c'est écrit sur le rapport oui et vous
sortie du bar chez lucienne vous aviez
vous car tu prends avec des épis on peut
leur demander
on sort on se rappelait elle est là et
vous tu es blessé 7,65 je crois enfin
d'après ce que m'a dit un inspecteur qui
est venu voir ce matin souffrir
oui vous savez que à peu près une heure
avant que vous êtes tac on assassine un
professeur dans un parking d'aix j'ai lu
ça dans les journaux
il était en compagnie de françoise
muller vous la connaissez françoise
muller bien sûr une chic fille voulait
léguer néo garino ont travaillé ensemble
là bas et qu'est-ce qui vous ai
transportés ici après votre blessure
l'automobiliste qui passait par là m'a
pris dans sa voiture un brave type il a
même pas voulu se reconnaître votre
profession je travaille comme aide
soignante à la clinique des deux roses à
marseille depuis longtemps ça fait 2 ça
et avant que j'étais ou avant j'étais à
paris et vous avez partie pourquoi parce
qu'il faisait trop froid
bon c'est l'entrée
[Musique]
si m
mais bien bâti c'est ce que vous
reconnaissez cet homme il avait des
lunettes noires ils n'étaient pas
habillés pareil il avait un blues en ont
besoin comme un marrant je crois qu est
ce que ça veut dire au cinéma qu'en
afrique ou quoi on met ça c'est lui
c'est bien agi et puis quoi voyez me
dire ce qui se passe oui j'avoue nasa
n'est ce pas monsieur renaud jean
baptiste vous êtes sûr de ce que vous
affirmez à windham le sus tout à fait
j'ai eu dans ma mire baptiste travaille
à la clinique des deux roses à marseille
elle affirme que c'est vous qui avait
accompagné votre ami jean paul perreault
ni le matin du 18 mai avec une balle de
7 65 dans le ventre moi j'allais
prévenir médecin de garde
comme c'est arrivé il était parti fois
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
depuis ronnie j'ai appris avant-hier ce
qui lui est arrivé et puis je voulais 10
avec 1 02 63 mais ça ne croise pas
tellement loin d'aix en provence
et alors qu'est ce que vous voulez
insinuer que c'est moi qui bute et
professeurs c'est lui qui était
professeur
je vous remercie
l'essayer votre déposition
m
alors quoi les décrets ça va beaucoup
mieux en mieux aller series il vous
gênez pas inculper mois façon maintenant
je ne parle plus qu'en présence de mon
avocat
une caisse qui vous parle les
inculpations c'est sûr dont je tour très
serré avec vous même fait entrer
monsieur d'accord s'il vous plaît je me
suis d'accord nous gérons la même jupe
connaissaient ce monsieur je pars
l'honneur du sien dans l'orne enchanté
bon c'est tout lecture que vous n'avez
jamais vu ce monsieur rues désertes ou
non pas me croire je l'aï mois payés
sortir une seconde monsieur relance et
je finirai de les entendre tout à l'air
c'est d'ailleurs dans votre première
déposition la police vous avez parlé de
quatre coups de feu dont l'un était d'un
calibre différent
ah oui alors il faut m'expliquer servent
bien clairement le borgn' et c'est un
revolver plus petits le tout premier
6,35 7,65 quelque chose comme ça
d'abord les trois autres je suis sûr que
c'était de la grosse artillerie autant
qu'un j'ai appris à reconnaître les
armes à l'oreille un bon manuel muller
elle recevait beaucoup de monde non à
bord de supports entier jamais vu
personne
eh bien je remercie monsieur des gardes
[Musique]
suis là avec tout ce qu'il boit son
témoignage ne s'intéressera pas grand
monde sauf moi ni colère et c'est
suffisant
professeur des parkings c'est sûr
maurice qui leur passait il avait dû
mettre à la mode
un rapport à la film j'ai été témoin les
engueulades karine ont professé rennella
soir pour s'expliquer avec maurice
cancer j'sais pas moi
trois semaines un mois à peu près j'ai
entendu le début le professeur a dit
j'ai payé avant ça suffit comme ça et
comment tu savais qu'il était professeur
tout le monde en parle j'en ai par tous
les amis de maurice continue tu
intéresse beaucoup monsieur le
commissaire
tout ce que je peux dire c'est qu'il
avait les rangs pétards le professeur
alors maurice la feyssine de parler plus
bas et il l'a entraînée dans l'arrière
salle hors sac de rage
on attendait un peu à travers la porte à
un moment professeur il a traité maurice
de maître chanteur
je me rappelle bien ça durera peut-être
cinq minutes il est sorti en disant ne
comptait plus sur un centime
je ne suis pas une vache à lait et redon
qu'est ce qu'il a dit
bienvenue au comptoir et l'a lancé je
vous attendent tout de même le 17 à 8
heures réfléchissez bien monsieur
plantier messieurs à domicile vous plaît
monsieur la même chose
et bien entendu ce que vous venez nous
raconter ne pourriez pas le répéter la
juge d'instruction
non ça c'est pas possible ce commissaire
ça me paraît difficile bon camarade
aimerait bien arriver jusqu'au troisième
âge et françoise muller vous la
connaissez
ça c'est pas un cadeau un d'après ce que
tu as eu l'air de me dire
elles étaient de mèche avec maurice
moi j'ai rien dit
facile
si vous cherchez par là et se pourrait
bien que
enfin si par hasard tu apprenais du
nouveau tu m'appelles à la brigade pour
toi tu sais que je suis toujours là je
sais ce commissaire charon bientôt taman
wii est tricards entre autres bricoles
mais il sait surtout que si je le
portais une petite histoire marseillaise
à travers les bars il finirait à la
morgue
la télé mensonge répété tous ces
personnages enfin qui sont des voyous
nommé excusez-moi constituent des
charges assez sérieuse ça à mon avis en
tout cas la libye de péronne il part
très très très solide
non non ce soi-disant manière avec des
arabes qui on n'a rien entendu dans
celle que 7000 rien ici ça traîne ça
traîne c'est terrible je comprenais la
presse est déchaînée en inculpation tous
ces gens mettraient fin aux spéculations
de ceux qui veulent qu'ils veulent à
tout prix une affaire politique
nous avons la preuve par sa banque que
plantier attiré 235 millions fin avril
nous ne savons pas ce qu'il a fait de
cet argent enfin il est clair qu'il a
payé l'amendé une première fois et quand
redon a remis ce il sait qu'après ça
recoupe la version mon informateur ou
écouter commissaire ça les enseignements
de votre informateur m'intéresse
absolument pas tant ce qui concerne ses
millions il est probable il est probable
qu'ils ont bien servi à payer à mende ce
mois-ci vous dire une chose
rien ne me fait croire que müller a pu
conduire planté dans l'hôtel piège ce
que je crois moi c'est qu'elle est
tombée très très très amoureuse de
plantier et puis qu'ensuite et va les
trouver dans une situation absolument
impossible bah oui mais alors
qu'est ce que nous permet de penser ça
des petites choses
une intuition que j'ai observé moi j'ai
interrogé deux fois cette femme et j'ai
la conviction qu'elle tenait énormément
un plantier et quelque chose dans son
comportement dans la façon qu'elle
allait répondre de ne pas répondre c'est
passé peut-être des choses qu'une femme
me sens plus facilement qu'elle a
vraiment fait toujours inculpé redon et
ternir ma part au mieux françoise muller
est coupable d' entrave à la bonne
marche de la justice
ah oui m'enfin c'est pas grave quand
même puis ça mérite peut-être qu'on se
penche un peu sur le problème parce que
nous avons à maurice
mais ces messieurs ne m'ont pas laissé
le temps d'attendre et encore on dit
c'est pas possible c'est le goulag
ah non alors à toi tu la boucles à les
habituer bruit qu'est ce que vous voulez
encore
en fait pour lui une envie de prendre le
petit déjeuner avec toi pour bavarder un
mandat c'est lire un juge c'est déjà pas
en avant mais quand c'est une gonzesse
en plus il faut prévenir ton avocat
maurice ils n'ont pas le droit au
maintien on t'embarque aussi toi tu vas
nous accorde une interview à l'essor de
la sorte cela ne l'a pas violée on n'a
pas le temps tu dors avec des outils la
nuit j'ai peur des voleurs
eh ben voilà ça va te faire déjà une
inculpation détention illégale d'armes
etc ton pedigree tu gohelle tarif est
d'abord cessé de m'appeler ma cocotte je
ne suis pas votre cas
hot dégoûté et foutez moi la paix et pas
de nous mentir tuer les autres ou pour
complicité notre sûrement faire plaisir
et on perd on perçoit et il est tout de
même 100 sacs d'argent de poche tous les
mois alors c'est d'ailleurs à ça on a
profité de son fric mais bien sûr vous
avez raison
[Musique]
vous prenez pour une conne quoi croyez
que je me vois pas venir avec vos
grosses godasses
ah c'est pas moi qui prends bonne colle
c'est maurice re donc vous n'aimez pas
les exploiteurs et barry q vous allez
les gars t'es tu allez vous retrouver
sur le trottoir et 90 % de la recette
dans la poche de monsieur je vous trouve
pas très cohérente n'importe quoi en
tout cas c'est lui qui a tué gérard
plantié dans la nuit du 17 au 18 mai
n'était pas avec vous je vous ai laissé
nous mentir pendant des heures mais j'ai
la preuve de ce que j'avance tenez
connaissez peut-être pas celui là
non
jean-paul des rognons d'affaires jp pour
les amis cette condamnation proxénétisme
voilà armés
un idéaliste comme vous les aimez eh
bien il avoué il était avec votre romero
dans la nuit du 17 au 18 et ensemble ils
ont quel professeur plantier un homme
soit dit en passant qui est tout de même
plus près de vos idées que les gens du
milieu
non c'est pas la peine de continuer à
nous raconter des histoires peroni est
venu chercher redon à sainte croix le 17
ça vous pouvez pas dire le contraire
n'est ce pas un je ne sais pas moi c'est
peut-être lui qui est venu chercher
maurice mais j'ai pas son nom vers 5
heures et ils sont partis tous les deux
puis puis merise n'est rentré que le nom
de 8 heures je cherche je parce qu'ils
ont fait ensemble
il n'a pas voulu me le dire
bon ben moi j'ai bien avancé et je crois
que je suis très près de la vérité alors
j'ai inculpé maurice re dans le meurtre
et jean paul perreault lit de complicité
de meurtre voilà pourquoi est ce que
vous m'avez menti mais vous aimez tout
le temps et m'en tiens à tel point que
je me demande si je ne devrais pas vous
inculper aussi pourquoi est-ce que vous
ne m'avez pas dit que maurice redan
avait mis gérard plantié à l'amande tu
pousses que vous savez ce que c'est que
la mangue dans votre milieu
je n'ai jamais entendu parler d'amande
entre maurice et gérard c'est parce que
nous dit l'ami d'enfance de gérard
plantié monsieur georges godart n'a
jamais pu me voir celui là alors il
pourra vous dire n'importe quoi
pourquoi est-ce que vous ne m'avez pas
dit non plus que gérard plantié pour se
protéger je suppose en tout cas de
défendre s'était procuré un pistolet de
7,65
c'est encore gaudin qu'ils aient dit ça
patine en latin fini
vous savez que dans la nuit du 17 au 18
mai votre ex associé et l'actuel associé
de maurice redan a pris une balle de 7
65 dans le ventre alors qu'est-ce que je
prouve
vous pouvez bien évidemment
comme nous sommes parlé pour la première
fois mademoiselle vous l'avez dit vous
aimiez gérard plantié oui et j'ai même
ajouté que ça ne regardait que moi c'est
vrai et ce jour là je vous ai cru
aujourd'hui je sais plus du tout vous
savez au poids ou en l enquête tout
semble indiquer que vous saviez que
gérard plantié était attendu dans deux
parkings et puis alors faites votre
métier
inculpé moi mais moi je peux pas arriver
à croire que ça s'est passé comme ça moi
j'essaye de vous aider mademoiselle
muller et je suis bien la seule la
meilleure personne mais décès me croire
bon eh bien nous allons continuer à
essayer de démêler tout ça que là
[Musique]
avancez
oui
vous disposez
[Musique]
j'ai fait venir mademoiselle muller
parce qu'elle est probablement votre
complice à ça alors c'est pour on s'est
pas vu depuis plus d'un mois
d'abord at il autre chose non non mallié
du d'autres amateurs derrière elle
essaye encore de vous protéger je vais
me demande bien pourquoi elle m'a plaqué
pour ce type
elle me couvrir et enfin se tient pas
debout et coetzee marconnet dans le
quartier si tu m'as vu tu es plantier il
faut le dire si c'était vrai lyon
voudrait pas de me balancer selon c'est
pas vrai madame le juge
je les vois tu es ce professeur cette
nuit là j'étais avec evelyne fleuret
chez registre ia à sainte-croix plaid
sur des pieds
[Applaudissements]
le 17 mai vers 17 heures un homme
d'environ 30 ans est venu chercher
maurice il est parti avec lui et il
n'est revenu que le lendemain matin vers
8 heures j'étais un peu inquiète comme
maurice conduit très vite je pensais
qu'il avait eu un accident cetera et
cetera ferait à la police judiciaire
enfin vous savez bien que l'esprit qui
font dire n'importe quoi n'importe qui
ces fumées mais enfin madame jean
baptiste monsieur god damn aux elfes
leur aise quand ça fait quand même du
monde tous à trépas 1 alors vous allez
me dire ce que vous avez fait dans la
nuit du 17 au 18 mai en compagnie de
votre ami jean paul perreault ni parce
que quand on a présenté la photo de
monsieur peroni à mademoiselle fleuret
elle a parfaitement reconnu l'individu
qui venu vous chercher à sainte croix
vers 17 heures une conne pareil on lui
ferait prendre un autre proche cheval de
course et même jean baptiste ont ils
fait prendre quoi pourquoi et qui pour
qui c'est vous qui avez accompagné
péronier la clinique et votre fameux
blouson de cuir marron il est très très
connu dans certains bars de marseille
alors vous les fait disparaître un
ballon dont je fais tout disparaître les
blousons les professeurs les 7 65
pourquoi vous mettez ça sur le dos parce
que j'ai tiré sept ans de taule c'est
pas à cause de vous hanter c'est dingue
mais je vous ai fait recul perdant c'est
parce que tout est contre vous
look est des témoins et le système de
défense parce que vous mentez vous
mentez mal j'ai tous les éléments pour
vous envoyer en cour d'assises et je
vais vous y envoyer
il est une leçon
c'est moi qui tu gérer
[Musique]
je vous demande la permission d'avertir
mon avocat maître riez peine en sa
présence je dirais exactement ce qui se
passe
non
kiel
[Musique]
tremblay lagarde
quand quelque chose vous ce matin alors
ça y est la fille elle avoué oui bah dis
donc j'amène ton fils dimanche soir on
conserve 2
d'accord qui est le cas
l'avocate françoise muller rival bonjour
madame et redon qu'est ce qui vous a
raconté ce matin avait il a reconnu
qu'il avait menti sur son emploi du
temps mais il a un nouvel alibi il était
bien avec son ami un péroné au bar chez
lucienne maison joue au poker avec des
amis avec des années avec des amis
qu'ils s'en souviendront certainement
et puis la suite vous la connaissez ils
ont été agressés par les algériens la
sortie
les couverts et c'est bien lui qui a
conduit son nez le père ni la qualité de
rose et françoise muller va s'arranger
pour que cet alibi tiennent le coup pas
difficile à moi sarkozy en revenant sur
la route tunis on s'est disputé dans le
parking il m'a insulté j'ai répondu moi
j'y fais alors je me suis plus
contrôlées chez ouvert la boîte à gants
j'ai pris son revolver à vous aviez part
conséquente qu'il était procureur à
l'ouvert j'ai tiré trois fois sur lui au
moment où il sortait de la voiture est
plus que je faisais ben ça ça colle pas
du tout avec les témoignages des gens
qui vous en rencontrez soir là après
deux missions télévision qui s'accordent
tous à dire que vous aviez l'air très
heureux plantier vous et c'est vrai mais
les choses ont changé pendant le trajet
ont changé au point que vous preniez le
revolver pour tuer planqué s'est mis à
parler de mon passé
en théorie et d'accepter tout mais dans
le fond il restait très attaché à ses
préjugés
j'ai traité de sale petit bourgeois
alors il m'a giflé en traitant de [ __ ]
et retour les nous siffler jamais serena
fois c'est à dire que votre orgueil
refuse la gifle ghanam alors que
l'excellent d'un autre je peux pas vous
expliquer aux mesures très simples et
marie se réglant c'était un homme parce
que plein pied c'était un cave c'est ça
de toute façon vous puisque vous voulez
ça m'est égal je vous dis que j'ai tué
gérard panthier s'est tous bien votre
version des fait les présidents trouve
ça s'est pourtant passé comme ça par
conséquent je suppose qu'il faut que je
fasse libérer maurice rdo ça me paraît
équitable mais vous allez quand même
expliquer quelque chose
comment se fait-il que gérard plantié
qu'yves et à 7,65 dans la boîte à gants
de sa voiture a été assassiné avec à 11
non mais qui a parlé d'un 7,65 ce genre
gaudin monsieur gaudin est certainement
un fin commentateur de schopenhauer et
permettez moi de mettre en doute sa
compétence en matière d'armes à feu
qu'est ce que vous avez fait de l'armé
du crime
jeudi j'étais dans un chantier à 200 m
de chez moi
ça y est je le hais
[Musique]
c'est bien on se 43 évidemment c'est pas
tellement surpris qu'on l'ait retrouvée
qu'est ce que vous feriez pas pour
sortir reconduit trouve toi m vous
croyez vraiment vous à la culpabilité de
votre cliente
on a tout même retrouvé l'armé du crime
sur ses indications oui on a retrouvé
l'armé avec laquelle le plan qui a été
tué ça c'est vrai
seulement c'est pas celle qui était dans
la boîte à gants non c'est pas celle que
plantier avait montré son ami serge
godin
ça n'est pas celle dont monsieur dagorn
d'accord monsieur dagorn qui était
volontaire en indochine a identifié au
sens ça n'est pas à 7 65
or la même nuit
jean paul perreault ni a été blessé au
ventre d'une balle de 7,65 où il tirait
par un arabe qu'on n'a jamais retrouvé
c'est bien commode quelquefois les
érables à m moi j'ai pas de conseil à
vous donner à nicolas fait entrer
mademoiselle muller ce couplet gardien
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
tâchez l'asthme quand votre première
déclaration vous m'aviez dit que vous
aviez rencontré gérard plantié au début
de l'année
oui or georges goda dans sa déposition
que je vais devenir affirme que plantier
vous a connu ou plutôt vous connaissez
depuis environ deux ans enfin tout
dépend de son appel connaître c'était
brugirard comme clients excusez moi
j'appelle pas ça connaître à l'époque où
je travaillais j'avais la visite en
moyenne de 5 à 6 m par après-midi alors
dire quand j'ai vu gérard pour la
première fois je tenais pas de registre
oui je me permets d'ajouter aux dames le
juge que ma cliente n'était pas une
prostituée de re mais qu'elle exerçait
en studio je sais je sais m comme client
et c'était un client normal tout à fait
normal c'est assez rare donc un client
propose le mariage à une femme qu'il
paye il ya eu un moment où je rare est
venu me voir souvent de trois fois par
semaine et un jour après jour c'est très
différent je te dire c'est à dire qu'une
fille qui se respecte ne s'en va pas en
l'air avec ses clients
[Musique]
j'ai pas ça alors je lui demande est une
pure venir par fidélité à ardon et il
est revenu il est parvenu pendant un
certain temps et puis un jour j'ai vu
réapparaître
j'avais pas reconnu sa voix au téléphone
il a même chose s'est passé et là vous
avez commencé à vous attaché à lui je
m'entendais bien avec lui c'était le
premier document risqué mais bien
souvent après on parlait m'avait dit
qu'il était professeur
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé comme
campredon est sorti de prison jeudi à
gérard et là je vais vraiment demandé de
ne plus revenir
puis j'ai arrêté de travailler il
pouvait plus le choix comment est-ce qui
vous a retrouvé par hasard la sortie
d'un cinéma où j'étais allé seul c'était
une époque où maurice m'étais laissé
bon alors à ce moment là vous avez revu
plantier dans des conditions différentes
si on veut mais là j'ai vraiment
l'impression de tromper maurice et redon
et s'en est aperçu vous avez un amant
pas tout de suite
de toute façon marie je ne voyais pas
toutes les nuits et voulait n'est encore
oui et c'est lui qui détache et demain
alors est ce que ce ne serait pas pour
essayer de le rattacher à vous que vous
avez fait semblant de vous attacher ap
entier j'ai jamais fait semblant et un
moment où j'ai peut-être aimé deux
hommes en même temps mais je peux jouer
la comédie
oui enfin la situation tout de bien
servir à renault pour soutirer de
l'argent aux plantiers mais c'est faux
je vous ai déjà dit maurice n'a jamais
me gérard à l'amande
il était bien trop jaloux pour entrer
dans ce genre de combinaison comme
jaloux mais vous m'avez toujours dit que
je l'avais pris la chose très bien pas
le premier jour ça fait jamais plaisir
non et ce jour là et vous à gifler oui
et alors mais qu'est ce que vous essayez
de me faire dire pour vous tout ça est
simple on aime d'une seule façon qu'un
seul homme à la fois puis comme je suis
une [ __ ] je ne peux pas avoir aimé un
homme comme gérard bien si vous voulez
savoir je regrette qu'il soit manger et
est responsable de sa mort seulement
responsable c'est moi qui l'ait tué
gérard moi seul mais pas pour du fric
prie madame lycée marc thomé damas est
fatigué
[Musique]
plaisir mademoiselle muller
je
on était placée comme ça
on se disputait depuis un moment il m'a
insulté
moi aussi
[Musique]
et il m'a giflé
m
il a fermé le contact il a ouvert la
portière
[Musique]
c'est là que j'ai pris le revolver qui
était dans la boîte à gants
et vous avez tiré tout de suite non je
suis sorti de la voiture
mon prénom je vous prie
on se trouvait exactement la victime
après la gifle il est sorti très vite on
faisait face
oui c'est ça il me faisait face
alors je me suis avancé et j'y tiens
mettre fin ou la victime est elle tombée
à côté de la portière sur la portière
non pas sur la portière
à côté là et après qu'est ce que vous
avez fait je suis resté un moment sont
bouchées je réalisais pas très bien ce
que j'avais fait et puis je suis ici
j'ai traîné le corps alors tout de suite
comme ça vous avez pensé à maquiller le
crime
oui enfin au début c'est pas très bien
ce que je faisais gt gt coupé par free
pour une femme affolée vous avez agi
avec rapidité asie
[Musique]
allez-y repas ce que vous avez fait
je ne savais pas que votre fils était
musicien hier soir ça m'a coûté safran
sur le cours mirabeau
remarquez journée eu pour mon argent
performance pour un petit bout de femme
comme ça c'est bien
en revanche est plus du tout j'en suis
parce que je suis là je n'écoute
j'ai regardé mes regards bien droit dans
les yeux j'ai envie de la croire et je
la croyais tout d'un coup je la crois
plus du tout où c'est quelqu'un que je
comprends absolument pas et suivent en
moi cette volonté sa cuisine même cirque
ont pas tellement d'une certaine manière
cette fille doit sentir responsable
alors qu'est ce que tu veux il sue se
grandit vis-à-vis d'elle-même en allant
seul devant les juges ça me paraît
normal
oui mon travail c'est pas de favoriser
le masochisme tiens c'est essayer de
savoir ce qu'ils ont fait pourquoi ils
ont fait signe ont fait merveille et
bourré qu'est ce que tu veux moi cette
ville me plaît moi je la trouve je
trouve que c'est quelqu'un à personnage
peut pas de dire plus mais des personnes
âgées des personnages envoie toute la
semaine c'est moi moi j'ai pas dans un
roman russe merde
[Musique]
on dit tu pourrais pas dire qu'il allait
dire à quelqu'un qu'il fasse après -
aubry parce que je suis vraiment très
fatigué bonjour madame est maintenant
beaucoup ça va ça va mieux ce terrien
que les petites en chine le dossier des
cabinets par pierre et son habitation
jouer on vous fait entrer contraire je
viens de recevoir le rapport des experts
en balistique
alors les balles qui ont tué plantier
ont été tirés à au moins trois mètres et
est la reconstitution vous n'était même
pas à mettre sur du compte je n'étais
plus et pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
traîné le corps ce qui n'a pas l'air
facile
jusque devant la voiture je ne sais pas
très bien envoyé ma cliente n'avait pas
autant de sang froid que vous le
supposez bon alors il veut le vert y en
a eu beaucoup
ça vous élus comme ça tout de suite et
tout seul l'idée d'aller enterrer
révolue
mais chantier n'est pas eu peur de
rencontrer quelqu'un je faisais déjà dit
je suis passé par la porte de secours
pour ne pas rencontrer le gardien oui
vous m'avez déjà dit c'est vrai mais dit
beaucoup de choses
il ya beaucoup de choses que vous voulez
pas dit plus parce que vous avez hissé à
des lois qui ne sont pas les nôtres qui
sont souvent aussi dur que des nouveaux
pères
je ne comprends pas ce qu'il m'est si
vous ne comprenez même aux nues l'air
parce que vous êtes très intelligente
plantier a déjà payé une amende une fois
rld on le remet à l'amande et lui donne
rendez vous pour le 17
planté ne va pas à ce rendez vous alors
dans la nuit du 17 au 18 e d'or
accompagnée de perdre y vais attendre
plantier du parking et comme plantier se
sent menacée il sort son 7,65 de la
beauté
les tirs sur peroni l'arasement que la
personne ou redon merdes ont
probablement des postes par trois fois
spa c'est renault qui a tiré
c'est faux alors peroni à une balle dans
le ventre plantier en a trois dans le
corps ça fait 4 ce sont bien les quatre
coups de feu dont monsieur dagorn
toujours parler mais jusque là rien ne
me prouve que vous soyez au courant de
ce rendez vous est donc donné à poitiers
tandis que l'ap crime
après le crime seulement c'est là que
vous devenez la complice de redon 8 rien
le musée muller et vous avez très bien
que moi je dis la vérité je suis la
seule coupable et je répondrai seul de
mon acte devant la cour d'assises est
votre version ne tient pas du tout
quelqu'un pas sa version sauf une chose
dont on est sûr c'est qu'elle a bien
téléphoné à police secours à 1h45 parce
qu'elle fixe qui le prouvent
or le médecin légiste est formel la mort
de plantier ne peut pas remonter à plus
tard qu'à une heure du matin
alors il ya un trou il ya un trou de 45
minutes entre le meurtre et l'appel au
secours
alors elle le comble en disant que le
meurtre a eu lieu à une heure trente et
qui est lui aussi que la attendu dix
minutes la communication avec eux aux
discours mais dans ma version
dans la version
le temps d'établir le scénario le temps
d'aller jusqu'au chantier le temps de
revenir cl ça fait le compte
elle arrive chez elle vers 13h40 et à
1h45 à l'appel bien pas les secours
n'ont souhaité couvrir dont vous avez
peur de redon je n'ai peur de personne
savait la loi du silence
alors à bon dos comme vous seraient en
prison pendant des années des années
je vous remercie de vouloir m'aider
madame mais je vous ai dit la vérité
alors qu'on en finisse une bonne fois
pour toutes en finir mais c'est que nous
allons pour voir très souvent de moselle
muller parce que l'instruction sera
longue à temps si vous vouliez revenir
sur ses aveux les charges qui pèsent
contre vous semble sont légères
ça veut dire quoi revenir sur les
saveurs vous me prenez pour qui
vous serez derrière vos barreaux
monsieur redon mènera la joyeuse vie
le reste ne m'intéresse plus
je vous dis que j'ai tué gérard plantié
le dit fumer à 1h30 du matin vous pouvez
interroger toutes les choses en a 200 je
ne vous dirai pas autre chose
[Musique]
ma
c'est tendre et clients c'est pas cher
pour personne la classe et l'histoire
c'est renault qui a fait le coup
mais
tu vois elle a tenu le coup
[Applaudissements]
ouais jury faudra que je comprenne
comment la chambre d'accusation a pu
prononcer non lieu c'est très long
[Musique]
celui là finira sans doute dans un
règlement de comptes qui s'est servi du
colt périra par le col
[Musique]
quoi
non
on
elle
[Musique]
non
là
[Musique]
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
lui
où
m
[Musique]